hi everyone welcome to who pays for open
access the fourth and six events in the
research Without Borders speaker series
sponsored by the scholarly communication
program at the University columbia
university libraries I'm Kathleen dryer
the head of the Watson library of
Business and Economics at Columbia
University we have three panelists today
Mike rosner avi Anderson and Bettina
Gerner Mike rosner did his PhD in
molecular biology in the laboratory
professor sir ken Murray at the
University of Edinburgh he was managing
editor of the journal of cell biology
journal the Journal of cell biology from
1997 to 2007 in 2006 he was promoted to
executive director of the Rockefeller
University Press mr. Roslyn received the
spark innovator award in 2009 for his
efforts to promote data integrity and
public access to scholarly research avi
Anderson sitting on the end here in
purple this is a director of collection
development and management at the
California digital library miss Anderson
was the lead for the California digital
library on making the University of
California the first US institution to
support the sponsoring Consortium for
open access publishing in particle
physics and on concluding an agreement
with Springer to make all University of
California author articles available as
open access under the Springer open
choice license Betty garner said Bettina
garner sitting here in the middle study
biochemistry and molecular biology and
carried out research for her master's
thesis at the Max Planck Institute for
biophysical chemistry in göttingen
germany after her studies she gathered
work experience at the Harvard
Institutes of medicine McKinsey &
Company and NCI in october two thousand
eight ms garner joined springer as a
management trainee working on projects
in editorial marketing and e product
management sorry and innovation areas
after showing early interest in open
access she was appointed manager open
access and Springer's business
development unit so we're going to do
right now is mr. Rosner will speak first
give his presentation
then miss Anderson and then miss Turner
then after they give their presentations
we'll open it up for questions so I
wanted to read their BIOS first get it
out of the way so might take it away and
also i should say this of course i
forgot we're videotaping the event today
so when you do ask questions please use
the microphone in the middle and I think
that's everything I wanted to say well
thank you for the introduction thank you
to Katherine let's get there oh there
Thank You Katherine for the invitation
to be here and thank you all for coming
on this beautiful day instead of having
your lunch outside I'm Mike rosner the
executive director of Rockefeller
University Press we published three
biomedical research journals the Journal
of cell biology the journal of
experimental medicine and the Journal of
general physiology now I have two
subtitles for this talk today the first
is practical and I'll start with some
definitions that are relevant to this
discussion and then I'll describe what
we've been able to do as a
subscription-based publisher to provide
public access to the biomedical research
articles that we publish second
subtitles a bit more provocative and
I'll read from an article that I've been
working on that's describing what i
think is the most important development
in the public access movement over the
last few years okay to start with some
definitions and of course the definition
of open access now is all sorts of
colors associated with open access gold
green yellow blue I haven't be
colorblind and so I have very difficult
time making sense of all those colors so
I'm going to start with the most basic
definition and that is free access of
scholarly research articles to the
public immediately after publication the
basic is that publishers who provide
this kind of access can't sell
subscriptions so they recoup their costs
through an author page model or
advertising or some form of subsidy and
I'll describe more about subsidies later
in the talk now I know it's not the
focus of this discussion today but there
is an element of copyright in the
definition of open access and that's the
concept of free reuse of published
content by third parties without
permission so in addition to free access
there's supposed to be no barriers to
reuse of the content second definition
public access i define public access as
free access to scholarly research
articles to the public at some defined
time point after publication if that
time point is zero you're talking about
open access if that time point is
greater than zero you're talking about
delayed public access I don't use the
term delayed open access that's an
oxymoron open access means immediate
access publisher should provide delayed
public access recoup their costs by
keeping their content under access
control for a short period of time to
sell subscriptions so we sell rolling
subscriptions again in my opinion
there's also a concept of copyright for
the definition of public access and that
is the concept of free reuse of
published content by third parties
without permission from the publisher
unfortunately they're not all that many
publishers that adhere to that principle
so why do we at Rockefeller University
Press support public access to scholarly
research articles well first of all we
work for a university that has the
mission ciencia pro bono humana generis
science for the good of humankind
as the press department of that
university our mission is to disseminate
knowledge as broadly as possible we do
this to promote scholarly communication
in the advancement of science and we do
this by keeping as little as possible
under access control a second reason why
we support at by at Rockefeller
University we support public access to
scholarly research articles is that we
feel we have an obligation to the public
the public funds much of the research
that we publish they fund many of the
scholars the salaries of those scholars
who carry out peer review on our behalf
and they fund many of the library's
either directly at state institutions or
indirectly through grant overhead that
by our subscriptions so given our
mission and our obligation why don't we
publish open access journals what's the
barrier to open access for our journals
and the basic answer is that their
selective journals by that I mean we get
a large number of submissions we carry
out stringent peer review thus we have a
high rejection rate publish a small
number of papers and as a result the
cost per article is very high now I just
had our finance director redo this cost
evaluation last week and our cost per
article is nearly exactly ten thousand
dollars that's per article that's only
for online publication I pulled out all
our printing and distribution costs I
even pulled out the cost of our
circulation personnel who wouldn't exist
if we were open access ten thousand
dollars per paper I do not yet know of
any funder willing to pay that much per
article some examples that we have the
Berkeley Open Access Fund has a limit of
three thousand dollars on it the
Wellcome Trust which is getting funds
only very small
portion of what we publish they have the
highest dollar amount that i know of for
open access funding and that is five
thousand dollars only half of what it
costs us to publish our papers so of
course you're asking yourselves why or
cost so high well as I said we do very
stringent peer review we have a very low
acceptance rate in 2009 across our three
journals we had approximately five
thousand submissions we published about
500 papers we only publish ten percent
of what came in and to efficiently
process all of those manuscripts through
the peer review process takes take staff
we have an editorial staff of 17 people
our primary costs are staffing costs we
also still believe in high quality
production I know not all people do
anymore but we do and we have a large
production staff of production staff of
14 people who do copy editing and also
work to ensure data integrity for
example we have two full-time employees
who examine every figure in every
accepted manuscript for evidence of
image manipulation before publication
that cost money so I just want to point
out you know although the cost for
dissemination of information has come
down in the Internet age there is still
a cost for online dissemination of
information again that figure of ten
thousand dollars that i gave you is for
online only production does not include
printing journals at all so with all
those factors what is our business model
we release all of our content to the
public six months after publication
we've done this since 2001 so we've done
it for more than nine years and our
revenues increased every year through
2009 we are selling subscriptions to
content within the first six months
after public
we sell on rolling six months worth of
content as a subscription we do not
offer an open access option and this is
the process whereby subscription-based
publishers I take an extra fee from
authors to make their articles open
access while still selling subscriptions
and this has become known colloquially
as double dipping okay so why don't we
offer an open access option well we have
both a practical and a moral objection
to the open access option the practical
objection is that we don't believe in
providing spotty immediate access to
just a subset of our content based on
the ability of an offer to pay an extra
fee we want to make all of our content
available to the public and we do that
after a short delay and the moral
objection is that this options been
hijacked by subscription-based
publishers to provide even more revenue
for their coffers on top of their
subscription revenue while many I would
say most have not willingly changed
their overall public access policies
they're not releasing that all of their
content at any point so given the high
cost per article of publishing in a
selective journal is it possible to
publish the selective journal under an
open access model that is to make all
the content free immediately and the
answer is yes with subsidies to author
payments and these subsidies can take
the form of grants one example is the
public library of science that got many
millions of dollars in grants as startup
money they can take the form of
memberships both applause and biomed
central sell memberships to institutions
these usually come with a reduced our
article charge to the authors of that
institution but these seems suspiciously
like subscriptions to me
another way to subsidize a selective
open access journalist to sell the news
content an example of that is the
British Medical Journal they make all of
their research content open access and
sell subscriptions to the news content
they've a very large news section I'll
use bmj again is an example another way
to subsidize is to sell subscriptions to
other journals in a stable of journals
so the bmj group publishes a whole lot
of journals almost all of them are
subscription-based they offer no
research content open access and that's
subsidizing the open access in their
flagship journal to the research papers
and a final way to subsidize author
payments is by publishing an archival or
high volume open access journal and a
very successful example of that that
many people are aware of is plus 1 which
is subsidizing the open access for the
selective journals that are published by
plus and i'll finish here with one more
definition i'll define an archival
journal and i'm defining an archival
journal is one that applies a lower
stringency of peer review reviewers that
these journals usually ask if the data
support the conclusions but they don't
ask whether the work represents an
advance in the field selective journals
apply that second criteria with this
lower stringency archival journals are
able to publish a high percentage of
submissions they can publish a lot of
papers and the cost per article is low
ok that's it for the practical part now
I'm going to read you an excerpt from an
article that I've been working on it's
called updating realistic access and it
is an update to an article that was
published in the Journal of cell biology
six years ago now that was called
providing realistic access and the
subtitle is universal public access
mandates will reveal the value of
biomedical research
journals the most important development
in the past six years in the public
access movement has been the mandates
from funding agencies and research
institutions the most prominent of these
is the NIH mandate which requires that
the published results of NIH funded
research be made accessible to the
public within a year of publication the
federal research Public Access Act which
has been introduced to the US Congress
seeks to extend this mandate to several
other federal funding agencies globally
numerous other governmental and private
funding agencies have instituted similar
policies or stricter ones which require
release to the public within six months
research institutions have also begun
mandating such public access through
their own repositories the institutions
however must also respect the need for
publishers to recoup their costs by
providing a short embargo we have shown
that six months is reasonable before
releasing content to the public all
biomedical research funders and
institutions should mandate public
release of content six months after
publication when all biomedical research
publications are available to the public
an economic layer will be added to the
definition of selective versus archival
journals selective journals published
content that can be sold in the first
six months after publication archival
journals published content that few
people are willing to buy during the
first six months after publication and
they have to recoup their costs through
an author page model or some other non
subscription model currently librarians
are paying for archival content that has
kept perpetually under access control if
all biomedical research articles were
free to the public after six months and
librarians had the ability to choose
individual journals at reasonable prices
they would only subscribe to those
journals with quality content to which
their users demanded access during the
first six months post publication but is
there enough value left in selectivity
to provide this demand
has the revolution in searchability
negated the utility of selective
journals as filters of information that
is is there still a value to the
stringent peer-review process used by
selective journals or should all
publications appear in archival journals
as one editor has noted selective
journals prioritize and streamline
information for busy readers and provide
a hierarchy admittedly and perfect for
appointments promotions and grant review
there is a value to knowing that the
editors and reviewers of a selective
journal thought that a particular piece
of work was a significant advance in a
field people are still willing to pay
for that value and I believe will
continue to do so for some time in the
words of one observer of the scholarly
publishing publishing industry charging
for information is a clear-cut way to
know how valuable it is for biomedical
research journals I would modify that
statement to say charging for
information in only the first six months
after publication is a clear-cut way to
know how valuable it is thanks very much
and now Miss Anderson so I've called my
talk transforming the marketplace angels
and demons and if any of you heard me
give a talk at the spark forum last
summer this is to say some of the same
ideas and the same content just update
it a little bit but it's a similar theme
and the theme here is that we've tended
to pit subscriptions and open access
against one another but increasingly I
personally am interested in finding the
sustainability point that keeps access
as broad as possible and affordability
as low as possible and that may in some
cases be open access and in other cases
it may not be so a little bit of
background in context we talked a little
bit about the publishing environment and
the big deal environment I'm and I'm
going to talk specifically about four
different initiatives that we've been
engaged in
at the University of California our
support for scope 3 and our spring are
open access pilot and also the Berkeley
research impact initiative which is a
publishing fund that Mike referred to
before as well as CDLs a scholarship
publishing service and some of what we
see as next steps for us so I think many
of you know CDL but for anyone here who
is who is not familiar with CDL in the
University of California where attend
campus system 9 research universities
and one health sciences campus CDL
handles licensing activities and many
other coordination activities involving
digital initiatives on behalf of the
full university so we do license most of
the system-wide journal content
available at the University so um UC
faculty are very strong supporters of
open access of course that's one can't
make a blanket statement theses a big
tent and there are many different
perspectives but from a policy
perspective those faculty who engage
most closely with the library serve on
our system wide faculty library
committee are very staunch supporters of
open access they've recently written a
letter to the university president
asking CDL which is part of the Office
of the President to work on their behalf
to create more open access options to
support things like purple legislation
and so forth so there's a very strong
directive from our faculty Advisory
Committee to explore open access options
and and create more open access
availability and one of the founders of
clause Michael Aizen is at Berkeley and
the Berkeley Lab and so there's a
connection there that you can see but
even though these faculty are very very
strong in their support of open access
they also want their lives to work well
and easily and so we also hear from
faculty that they don't really want to
have to publish somewhere else you know
don't tell us where to publish just make
it easy for us to publish in the venues
that we already want to publish in of
course we also hear that faculty don't
don't necessarily want to pay article
process
these so there's a lot of concern about
the impact on on their own individual
budgets or research budgets if they're
forced to pay article processing fees we
have a very strong institutional
repository at UC in our east scholarship
service but it's it doesn't attract as
much content as it might because there's
too much overhead and depositing to
institutional repositories many faculty
of our faculty want to deposit but they
want it to be easy they want it to be a
byproduct of other things they don't
want to have to do something specific or
extra in order to take advantage of
those services the faculty have said to
us at the CDL that the university should
should negotiate on their behalf to
produce open access solutions but they
should be they should be convenient to
us a research also tells us many of the
things that Mike was just talking about
that what scholars want from their
publishing outlets of course rigorous
peer-review stature and selectivity is
is very important to faculty these these
findings there's nothing new here but
they are validated as they often are any
time the subject is studied this is a
recent study at the Berkeley Center for
the Study of higher education called
assessing the future landscape of
scholarly communication and it was some
in-depth interviews with faculty and a
range of disciplines so impact factor
journal brand as an important part of
that selectivity one quote from that
study peer reviewed prestige
publications are the coin of the realm
in tenure and promotion and a
particularly interesting finding I think
from this study was that the younger
authors younger graduate students of
tech-savvy folks are still still
choosing the traditional options and of
course I think we all know that as well
those are the folks who have most
vulnerable whose careers need
advancement their career depends on
being published in the best outlets and
so that reinforces a very conservative
approach to publishing so that all of
that reinforces publishing in the
outlets in the in the
that are that already extent and have
half prestige and have brand and that
leads us immediately to the large
publishers and the big deal so they're
not all large publishers are some very
small publishers that also our prestige
publishers but as we know many of our
journals are are published by except by
our colleague mega publishers and if you
look at if you look at the data over
time and this is a chart that's taken
from the association of research
libraries I think many of you are
probably familiar with this chart or
various iterations of it that have been
published over the years it does show
quite clearly that it with the advent of
the large what's called the big deal
that that many libraries and consortia
now now participate in serial unit cost
has has really gone down significantly
so between between say two thousand and
two thousand six I think it's the end
point of this particular chart serial
unit cost declined by a hundred and
eighty percent that's significant the
number of serials purchased increased by
fifty percent that's also significant so
even though serials are still at a very
high point on that chart which is the
problem for us the cost is still high
relative to our budget budget capacity
the the affordability of that content or
the unit cost of that content has gotten
has gotten a little bit more favorable
so there is some increased access and
and cost control that we've achieved
through these through these deals so I
think the library motivations for
supporting open access and for
negotiating big deals which are often
pitted against one another are really
some of the same motivations we're
trying to do what we can to reduce the
overall cost of the scholarly publishing
system in the case of open access we do
that to place market pressure on high
price publishers and I think that sense
of competition has driven down pricing
from some of the larger publishers and
also experimenting with more sustainable
publishing models and business models on
the big deal side we're trying to reduce
the
we're all costs by placing market
pressure on the high price publishers
through negotiation through aggregating
spend and reducing that that cost and
sis and seeking a more sustainable unit
cost similarly you the desire to
maximize information for users open
access clearly does that in the sense
that it's open so no barriers there big
deal similarly you're embracing more
content and so conceivably you're
expanding access etc so in some respects
one can see that the drivers here are
similar and maybe we shouldn't really
pit these against one another the the
one thing that's missing in many of the
big deals is that a third bullet point
that Mike had in his slide about reuse
and the ability to reuse content and so
broad use permissions and use rights and
that's where some of the some of the
barriers and some of the unhappiness
lies in some of this commercially
licensed content for subscription
content so the premise here is that
maybe the traditional publishers the
existing publishers are not our enemies
but that we can sort of turn them into
into our better angels by working with
them to try and and explore alternative
business models and that transforming
those public those publications is an
appropriate path to experiment with and
that's led to a couple of the
experiments that you see is involved
with so even Stuart schieber at Harvard
who is not a supporter of the kind of
hybrid open access model that we've
engaged in with with Springer has argued
that in order to convert existing
publishers to a gold open access model
we have to make it possible for a
publisher to convert to that model and
that's really the premise of some of our
experiments particularly our experiment
with the Springer and scope three so
these are two initiatives that you see
engaged in early on one was a support
for the scope three project which I'll
talk about in a minute and the others
are spring our open access
toilet both of these have the goal of
experimenting with converting existing
journals to an open access model they're
also similar in that they maintain the
library's role in the funding and
negotiation process we're not just
telling authors go pay article
processing charges were trying to
mediate that relationship and and
facilitate that arrangement and they
both involve deposit of final published
articles into open access repositories
institutional or otherwise so scope
three is and many of you may be well
familiar with this so I won't spend a
lot of time on it it's an initiative
based at CERN to convert core
high-energy physics journals to open
access the idea behind scope three is
that one would take the existing
expenditures for subscription journals
in those fields and that is a unique
field in which much of the publishing is
concentrated in a small number of
journals you take the money that the
subscription expenditures that are
directed to those journals and migrate
them over to a pooled fund that becomes
a funding consortium thus the notion of
a sponsoring Consortium for open access
and the consortium itself would manage
the publishing and peer review process
it would essentially outsource the
publishing process to publishers but
that would be more of a contractual
relationship and the consortium would be
would be managing the peer review and
managing the distribution of articles
into those journals this initiative has
been just dating for a while and it has
not achieved yet the the critical mass
that it needs to actually go forward and
become an active project it is still
going forward however right at this time
and they've received about seventy
percent of the the funding that they
believe they need and it's still
something that we're interested in
supporting as an exploration for various
ways of organizing funding and
organizing business models our open
access pilot with Springer was another
first in the u.s. initiative that you
see undertook we negotiated this
arrangement with Springer in 2008
effective for the two thousand nine and
two thousand ten years of our license so
it's a two-year pilot under which all
you see authored articles are published
with full and immediate open access
using Springer's open choice paradigm
this was negotiated as part of our
license fee for the journals we did
there was no increase in our license fee
for the journal so essentially we are
paying Springer what we were paying to
bring her the day before the pilot we're
still paying that same amount or
whatever we had negotiated for the for
that subscription period so we are not
at this time paying any additional
author fees for the open access benefit
and I think Bettina will have some
things to say about that when she
follows my my talk it's any you see
author is eligible for this not just the
corresponding author there's some tricks
to figuring out and making that work as
you'll see in a minute but it's similar
to arrangements that Springer has had
with Max Planck University of gooding in
the Dutch University Consortium some of
you may have seen just yesterday or
today that that agreement with Max
Planck is no longer in effect so upon
renewal that relationship is changing
and again I think patina we'll talk a
little bit about Springer's evolving
views about this model and finally the
UC published articles are deposited
automatically in CD LZ scholarship
repository so that's a function of the
transaction between springer and CDL
that those articles are made available
for us to harvest automatically into
into our repository we have a plan to do
some assessment of this pilot in this
year we haven't really started that
formal assessment project yet we're just
gathering ideas for it right now so the
way this works for authors when an
accepted author submitting author is
papers accepted they go through a series
of acceptance screens and one of those
screens they're invited to select the
institution that they're affiliated with
in order to act through a drop-down menu
in order to complete the acceptance
process and if they select the right
institution
they are told that their article will be
made available as open access at no cost
so it's a very straightforward process
using Springer's online submission
system and acceptance system when we
announced the pilot faculty responses
that you see were very very positive my
favorite one there's a third one there
that says your experiment is a
monumental event that could define a new
paradigm that will forever change the
scholarly publishing landscape well
Wilson will see that sounds good however
the faculty uptake has been not as high
as as that and we are going to be doing
some assessment in this year to figure
out why my suspicion is that this is
really a mechanical issue that this it's
the submitting or corresponding author
who has to actually implement the open
access provision because they're the
ones who are presented with those
screens and that may not always be a UC
author so there is communication that
has to happen I'm guessing that even
when that corresponding author is a UC
author they may go through this process
quickly and not pay attention you know
our first when we first announced this
we did a lot of marketing and publicity
we have a web page about it on various
websites that the libraries manage
including our scholarly communication
site for faculty but I think we all know
that awareness of things like that tends
to degrade over time so my guess is that
the issue here is awareness and not an
explicit desire by some faculty not to
publish their articles in that way
although there could be some of that as
well and so we do want to study study
those things so some differences between
the approach of scope three and then the
Springer approach in the case of scope
three the control of the journals does
move to the funding consortium and the
peer review and editorial functions are
really outsource kind of more of a
almost contractual basis and the
Springer arrangement the rights remain
with with with the author but the
control of the journals remains with the
publisher so it's really changing the
funding model but not necess the
structure of the relationships in the
industry relationships very much again
this notion of transforming existing
journals and some of the
benefits that we see in experimenting in
this direction it's not disruptive for
authors it supports their existing
reward system it doesn't it doesn't
invite them to publish in some other
outlet than other than those that they
would otherwise be choosing it leverages
existing relationships and funding
streams so right now we we handle hand
publishers a pretty big check and we
could still hand publishers a pretty big
check and that's one financial
transaction so it preserves some of the
efficiencies that are inherent in some
of their relationships it seems scalable
we can negotiate that relationship again
on behalf of the institution it can
affect a large number of journals at
once if an arrangement like this it's
affected with a with a large publisher
it also allows us and the library to
support authors who lack research
funding and therefore would not be
likely to have funding that they can
draw upon to support article processing
fees so I you know humanities Social
Sciences early career authors that don't
have a deep pockets one thing that we we
do like also about the Springer
arrangement and this would be true of
scope 3 as well as it avoids version
proliferation so there's some concern
about the multiple versions of articles
that are floating around in various
repositories and the inability to make
the published version of record the open
version and an arrangement like this
eliminates that that confusion or that
issue by making the version of record
the one that's available there are
certainly many challenges in pursuing
this model obviously a small number of
institutions have done this with
Springer but most of the content is
still subscription-based content we
don't really know how the cost picture
is changing for Springer so how can we
leverage our expenditures and make sure
that we're keeping costs under control
in contraction of the funding base i
think is a general issue that's of
concern for open access for some gold
open access publishing there are more
readers and there are authors so
subscribe subscriptions spread the
revenue burden across a much wider range
of players
and authorship does and so there's some
contraction that is going to wouldn't
tell us some in some cases significant
cost shifting if one thinks that this is
a process whereby more and more of the
content would become open access any
given journal then there's a point at
which some libraries will say well no
need to pay for this to subscribe to
this publishers journals anymore because
enough of them are open access and so
there would be some contraction of the
funding base through that mechanism and
there are other kinds of subscribers
like corporations which are a small but
not not zero percentage of this the
revenue picture right now so there's
some contraction potential contraction
of revenue that happens if you convert
to an author side system and in the
arrangement like the one we have with
Springer where the library is
essentially handing money to the
publisher in the way that we do
currently there's no obvious role for
funding bodies in that particular model
so some directions that we've thought
about we we regard all of this is
experimentation and something that's
helping us understand the marketplace in
the environment and will help us to
chart our next steps in this whole
scholarly communication of enterprise
embargoed access is one one possible
future for some kinds of journals and
that's essentially what Mike was talking
about is public access a short term
embargoed window of access and whether
that provides sufficient incentives to
maintain a subscription base and yet
will lead to more open access high wires
another example of that where many of
not most of the journals and high wire
have opened archives after I believe
it's a year or so and that may be a
model that works in some fields and not
in other fields and that's something
that you know we really need to
understand is where can Network and
where can't at work diversifying the
revenue stream in some in some ways a
combination of institutional funding and
article processing fees is a way to
diversify revenue and that's
characteristic of things like the
arrangements for nucleic acids research
biomed central etc so that might be a
direction that we could
pursue to have a certain level of
payment through the institution coupled
with lower article processing fees for
for authors organizations that don't
subsidize would then be subject to a
higher fee we've also thought a little
bit about submission fees and I just
want to say something about that I know
that there are some organizations that
are doing a little bit of study about
this right now but one of the one of the
arguments or some the contention that
many in the publishing industry have
have asserted is that part of the growth
in the cost of journal publication is a
result of the growth in journal
publication itself and this has been
studied by a number of folks showing
that there's been really a quite a
steady increase over time in the rate of
publishing over very long time frames of
about three percent per year and if you
look at between 1980 and 1995 for
example if you look at the growth in
research rd workers the growth in
articles that grows in journals they
also fall follow this same trajectory
and so there's just more stuff and more
stuff more stuff every year well so
we've got a little bit about and
meanwhile of course we hear that the
cost of peer review and and the cost of
selectivity is very high and as we see
increasing growth around the world we
also see that we r we libraries are
paying for that submission that increase
in submissions and so is there a way to
use submission fees to diversify revenue
streams there are some fields that do
have submission submission fees so in
this example this or a hypothetical
example it pegs the cost of the
worldwide journal publishing system at
eight point nine billion dollars which
I've seen figures of eight billion
dollars some though give her a give or
take a billion that's sort of where what
the current estimate seemed to be
articles published worldwide I've might
the most recent figure I've seen is 1.5
million
an average rejection rate has been said
to be fifty percent so if you do the
math and you assign a hypothetical
submission fee of a hundred dollars per
article which is not exorbitant that
would produce another 270 million
dollars under this calculation to the
publishing system as a whole obviously
more of that would flow to the very
selective journals but it tracks it
tracks reasonably well with the growth
in publishing so I know many publishers
have said the overhead and
administrative cost of processing
submission fees makes this unattractive
and not feasible and of course
publishers don't are competing with one
another and so very few publishers will
adopt something like this if their
competitors are not adopting a similar
model but again it's one way to think
about how the revenue stream might not
only be differentiated but also scale
with the activity that's actually going
on it might in fact dissuade some
spurious submitters from submitting
articles that they know won't get
published in a particular outlet and
that would then lower the publishers
costs so again just something that we've
been thinking about and trying to model
a couple of other projects that are
going on at you see that are not aimed
at the existing journals but at newer
journals one is the Berkley research
impact initiative and the other is our a
scholarship repository so the Berkley
research impact initiative is a fund a
special fund that the libraries and the
Berkeley office of research jointly have
put together to fund article processing
fees for Berkeley authors if research
funds are available to the author than
the feet the the fund cannot be used so
it's meant to supplement where research
funds are not available the fund will
sponsor up to three thousand dollars for
a full open access journal a so-called
gold Oh a journal and pink up to $1,500
for a hybrid journal it was an 18-month
pilot I believe it's been renewed so
it's still going on and the preliminary
assessment and there may actually be an
updated assessment but doing some of the
math I'm here
seventy-five percent of the articles
that were requested for which support
was requested were actually able to be
funded through research grants so the
fund only had to to sponsor 25% of the
requests and the average fee was about
sixteen hundred dollars so Berkeley is
estimated that their authors publish
about 5,000 journals per year if that's
the case then their total cost for
supporting authorship under this model
would be two million dollars their total
licensing fees for everything that they
license is 4.4 million dollars that
includes resources that that CDL license
is on their behalf as well as resources
they license locally so you know their
calculus is that this could lower the
institutional costs whether it lowers
the system costs is a very different
question but the focus here is on the
cost to the Berkeley library that is
interesting but many of these
publications haven't have had trouble
achieving financial viability so what if
we ourselves become the publisher we the
libraries the institutions and don't
rely on third parties that have a
different cost structure well this is
something that is exists that you see in
the form of our East scholarship
repository which has Rican sexualised
itself as more of a publishing platform
that a repository so there's more focus
now on the publishing service of these
scholarship then then the repository
function they support journals
monographs conference proceedings
working papers seminar series these are
all things that are published at UC by
UC faculty our authors are edited by UC
faculty or authors they also support or
i should say the service also supports
traditional repository services and
there's also a joint project with ec
press involving open access monographs
with a print-on-demand component that
the press support so that there's a
combined revenue model for print and
open access of the digital versions
we're probably going to see increasing
collaborations with the UC press and
future so this is just a screenshot of
the interface which has been recently
read
designed just to show you that it it
looks pretty robust and and and credible
it's a really nicely designed system so
how does the cost for publishing through
that mechanism compare with some of the
more traditional publishing costs and
much of much of my data here comes from
2009 report by Mark we're consulting for
at the STM organization which in turn
cites a lot of other work so it's a very
useful report to take a look at that
aggregates a lot of what is known and or
asserted about the industry and so one
of the one of the data points in that
that mark where pulls out is that the
cost of publishing articles in a
subscription journal on the average cost
is thirty eight hundred dollars there
was another study by the research
information network in the UK that had
twenty eight hundred pounds as that as
that number for a per article cost I
think some of these numbers obviously
need to be followed up and question
that's quite different from 10,000 per
article but that's this is an average
and not an individual journal that is a
high with a high rejection rate you can
see the components that go into that
cost first copy costs managing the peer
review process but also copy editing
typesetting this is again how this
particular study broke out these costs
variable cost per printing a print
distribution you know in an electronic
realm maybe you can knock those costs
out indirect costs for staffing and
overheads and that's something that will
vary depending on the organization the
type of organization and then surplus
which would be profit or in the case of
a non-profit a non-profit surplus that
that supports the organization and you
can see the percentage is there I about
forty percent i think is in first copy
costs and the rest is pretty much 20 20
20 so if you look at our East
scholarship service our at the rate that
we're currently ingesting content and
this this is not this is not necessarily
journal content this is also our working
papers conference
meetings the cost per unit is 475
dollars so that's a very basic
calculation that's based on our cost to
run and manage the repository and the
amount of content that we're taking in
every year as that content increases
certainly our cost would grow but not
just honest the unit cost would decline
over time and you can see that in the
archive repository where which ingest
about 58,000 articles per year the
annual cost for running the repository
now is about 360 thousand dollars plan
to go a little higher in the next couple
of years so the unit cost for ingesting
content there is six dollars and twenty
cents again these are you there's a
little bit of apples to oranges
comparison here perhaps a scholarship is
a publishing platform so it has some
publishing services and back-end
services for editorial management and so
forth archives does not have that but
even in a scholarship although our
platform is supporting the software that
manages peer review the actual
activities involved in peer review and
peer review management and editing are
handled by the editor the group that's
publishing that content whether it's a
journal or working papers or conference
proceedings from one of our research
units so those costs are completely
outsourced stay with the author so if we
look at all these things together I'm
just looking at some baseline data we
think you see publishes about 41,000
articles per year actually that's a very
squishy number so it could be it could
be lower but that's one number that
that's been pulled out our system-wide
journal licensing costs about 27 million
dollars per year that excludes campus
only subscriptions so maybe add
something to that maybe our total system
system cost is in the 50 million range
if we were supporting direct open access
through article processing fees at 3,000
per article it would be 123 million
dollars so that doesn't look like a good
deal for
I'm at fifteen hundred dollars per
article 61 million dollars that's
getting a little bit closer at the level
of an institution's repository that
really has very minimal cost that's when
we start to get below the cost that
we're that we're spending now or the
fees that were spending now if if some
of that revenue is supplied by research
grants then that begins to offset those
charges and the article processing fees
if the library is paying for some part
of that I'm start to look a little bit
better so next steps for you see so this
is this is this is kind of a sobering
picture of the the implications for a
large research intensive institution of
supporting article processing fees as
one route to open access and it tells us
that we have a lot really had a lot more
work to do so we're going to be
conducting a detailed assessment of our
spring or pilot including the author
uptake and some usage data some of the
cost implications we are interested in
additional pilots with other publishers
we're just very interested in exploring
and pushing on all of these directions
and we're going to be doing more
analysis and more financial modelling to
help us help us understand what the next
steps are thank you our final speaker is
Miss Kerner and then we'll open the
floor up for questions so start thinking
of questions now okay thank you very
much I will compliment the picture by
describing the point of view of a very
big publisher springer has been very
early involved in the open access debate
since 2004 we have experimented with
various business models and by now we
have quite a diverse ecosystem of open
access business models around I'm
responsible for them as spring us
manager open access and i would like to
walk you through them and then focus
especially on the institutional open
access expert
okay um two slides on Springer just so
you know how big we actually are we
publish 1800 journals which result in
hundred fifty thousand articles I would
just mention its 1.4 million articles in
total in annual output in science so
it's the tenth of this we further
publish 6,500 books per year and
twenty-two percent of the Nobel
laureates in the world publish with
Springer that's the number we are very
proud of we are very global company 60
publishing houses 20 countries 5,000
employees that should give you a good
picture and I stopped the corporate
advertising now so as I said spring and
open access is a long story already 2004
we pioneered open choice you have heard
this term we use quite a lot I go into
it in a little more detail but let me
walk through the different open access
flavors at springer and you can group
them in three pillars which is also
writes hybrid open access and fully open
access let's start with the first of the
rights what do we allow the scientists
to do with this article you might know
sharper Romeo which is the central
research that classifies the policies of
publishers when it comes to authors
rights we are grouped as a green
publisher this is as good as it can get
in this classification what does that
mean that means we allow our authors to
self archive your article being the
final office version not the springer
PDF Ed's your institutional repository
or your own website without an embargo
immediately if you would like to put it
into your friend s repository let's say
potential we ask for an embargo of 12
months but we do assist you in doing it
so we will be happy to deposit your
final of this version of your published
article
into PubMed Central and make it
available after 12 months this is the
green route mike has introduced us to
green versus gold obviously publishers
are more interested in the gold rude and
you see all the other models are
described now have to do with open
access journals or journals that offer
the open access option so the first is
hybrid open access journals that
traditionally our subscription journals
and they charge subscriptions and
content is behind access barriers but we
do offer the option to make your article
open access against payment of a fee and
when we do this we at least do it right
so we don't just open it which is free
access but we publish the article and
their creative commons attribution
non-commercial license which allows free
reuse and distribution for
non-commercial purposes copyright stays
with the author this is fully in line
with the official berlin declaration
budapest declaration where science
funders have defined what open exit
should look like the new spring a link
has just been rebuilt and you can see
that you can now filter for open access
articles so each open access article is
clearly marked as such and allows a nice
visibility of the open access output
edge bearing lizystuff renew each
article is marked as open access so we
are fully transparent about the
open-access article output in total and
/ general / discipline I show you a few
numbers in a little while so I just said
the open access option is available in
the majority of Springer titles there
are some journals where we don't publish
them ourselves but we only hold
distribution rights there we obviously
don't have it in place and sometimes
some society partners
I has it end of offering the open choice
option to the journals but you can
definitely say the default model for a
springer journal is the hybrid open
choice option if an author wants to pay
us for making its article open access
the fees 2000 hero three thousand US
dollar if your institution has an
experimental agreement with us such as
University of California the fees are
taking care of centrally and you don't
have to pay and I'll focus on this in it
in a while but let me quickly mention
our fully open access offering people
sometimes don't know that spring already
Paris is a proud number of 12 fully open
access journal again they are displayed
at the newly spring a link you can go
right to them it's 11 titles there one
just started this year and it's still
working on putting the first issue out
what's interesting now is how are the
business models resist these journals
you might wonder currently none of them
charges authors because the majority of
them has a sponsor for this channels so
if associated societies or institutions
take on the cost so they they pay the
article processing charge to Springer on
behalf of the authors so to just recap
then the models i just mentioned because
we are talking about business models and
I mean our goal is to identify the best
amusement model it's not only the
distinction between hybrid and fully
open access I mean this is clear what's
more interesting is the question which
is the right business model right and I
just mentioned three I said we charge we
can charge authors being at hybrid or in
fully we have institutional arrangements
where one institution takes care of only
their authors but for all journals and
then we have journal specific
arrangements where one sponsor takes
care of all potential office in the
world but just for this particular
journal and if you have any insights
which of the three options is the best
suited for the long-term development of
cordoba nexus I'd be very interested to
hear your premium when we talk about
fully open access biomed central was
mentioned earlier they are very strong
publisher in biomedical life science and
medical areas they published currently
200 journals we acquired them in 2008
which gave quite a bus in the community
some people were scared but I can
reassure you we will not touch this we
don't have any plans of integrating or
converting or whatever this is a clear
clear statement on the rethink this
business model is very interesting and
as Peter Suber stated nicely in October
to the night we now consider ourselves
even as the biggest open access
publisher just to talk about their
business models they charge off the fees
and they're very strong in the
membership model and they have two
memberships either the institution paste
the full article fees and they also
doesn't have to pay any phenyl at all or
they pay a little amount and the fees
for the authors are discounted I think
by twenty-five percent yeah so again
here it's the institutional approach one
institution taking care of its authors
in this group of journals or the author
pays by himself this summarizes the
three pillars I want you to introduce to
you and now let's look at at our open
access uptake across disciplines down
the left column shows you the
distribution of our articles across
disciplines you can see we are very
strong and medicine biomedical
scientists fields and maybe these fields
are generally stronger in science
at all in total of course and if you
look at the open access articles
distribution across disciplines that the
pattern looks pretty similar why is that
well definitely one of the reasons is
that our open access articles to third
come from institutional arrangements so
for two third of our articles this
payment barrier is solved right the
author does not have to ask himself do I
really want open access but I can't
really pay or I don't want to go through
the hassle of getting reimbursed for the
fees so if we remove the payment barrier
we see this pattern reflecting the
general publication pattern you also
notice that the uptake is particularly
strong and biomedical and life sciences
area and medicine think this is obvious
this areas are having the longest
history in open access with funding with
mandates and simply the familiarity with
open access is stronger in this field
now I mentioned the two third of our
articles come from institutional
arrangements so let's talk a little bit
about it two slides on how it works an
IV has just shown screenshots which I'll
update in a second we started with this
institutional arrangements already in
late two thousand seven with the
relatively small german university
getting in and that was soon followed by
arrangements with the Okabe the dutch
consortium of 13 universities was
followed by Max Planck which we believe
or I believe 25 institutes all over
Germany and Europe relatively recent the
UCL has joined and the very new deal is
University of Hong Kong deal as I be
mentioned earlier at the Max Planck
arrangement has just seized two weeks
after we started a new explain
with Hong Kong and talk about it in a
second IV mentioned that in our upon
acceptance the affiliation with the
author is created I will you see this is
redesigned and I try to communicate
better to authors what it means to
publish open access so i think the
uptake will grow we will see you know
higher numbers and sixty percent one
thing i want to mention although it
might be clear this is upon acceptance
right so the in the same holds true for
open choice payment of two thousand euro
the question of justly also pay is
completely separated from do we want his
manuscript published in our journal
right this Chinese wall between the
acceptance decision to to increase the
quality of the journals completely
separated by the eventually associated
revenue through open access fees or
through institutional arrangements now
let's talk a little more about sorry
let's talk a little more about these
pilots what have we learned from them
they were very helpful to increase our
number of open access articles which is
a good thing if you wanna you know
become familiar with what does it mean
to publish open access articles or two
authors what questions come up where do
we have to fix our backend how do we
communicate this properly we have not
seen increased increased submissions of
publications from any of the experiment
partners right so I be a strong one
quote when office said this will affect
my journal choice this is something you
might want to hope for but we have not
seen this happening and you can say you
are not surprised because we all know
that the number one factor to influence
and offers journal choice is the
journals impact right so we definitely
see this as well the open access option
where the fees are taking
by the institution do not increase the
published articles output from this
institution the second thing we looked
at in detail is usage how does usage
develop or differ for open access
articles from from tall access articles
and there are we see something very
interesting fifteen to twenty percent or
let me start again openx articles see
additional usage from public users so
users who are not affiliated with an
institution who has a license with us of
fifteen to twenty percent now what does
that mean every article at spring a link
has a certain amount of public usage
because sometimes we make articles
freely available for promotional reasons
if you just consider this a baseline and
you think now what on top is public
usage by by readers who otherwise would
not have access we see a significant
effect of fifteen to twenty percent we
have to keep in mind however that a lot
of it will probably be coming from
robots and crawlers who just try every
article based on springerlink and other
publishers platform and if it's freely
available or i should say openly
available they just download it yeah our
market research people estimate that
seven to five percent of this public
usage is actually artificial so by
crawlers and roberts this is of course
difficult to measure but i wanted to
share with you we definitely see an
increased public usage so the public
seems to make use of open access
articles talking a little more about the
business model of these experiments it
is very appealing to say to a
institution you pay us one hundred
dollars right now for your license deal
and of course we just substitute this
hundred you have you know no open access
arrangement with us and you pay 100
dollar for subscriptions and we just
substituted slowly against open air
right so you pay 20 now for open access
and you pay on the ATO bit for
subscription and total it stays the same
but you have prepaid your open access
component looks very appealing however
works only under two conditions one is
that all customers do this at the same
time and the second is people publish as
much as they read the second aspect is
clear right I mean Ivy mentioned it
earlier today people publish less and
David and the pattern is also different
right especially corporates read a lot
publish little but this is definitely a
fundamental ? to the open x gold open
access idea but let's talk about the
other aspect which I mentioned if we if
we now say to you you know you keep the
level at one hundred twenty percent is
for open access only 80 percenters for
the license then let's keep in mind that
for this twenty percent of open access
articles we can't sell them to anybody
else right so we are actually I mean
this is a strong disadvantage as long as
we see it as long as the transition
takes place and we don't have a switch
overnight so there is a certain risk or
you could say disadvantage to publishers
going into this transition s2 achiever
you mentions to achieve SS yeah there
needs to be a certain support for
publishers to step into this transition
and we believe that as long as the
transition takes place we need to ask
for extra payment of those who dare to
pioneer open access to compensate for
the losses that we make at other spots
it is important learning and we will see
how how we move forward the Hong Kong
University deal now does pay in addition
to its license because they recognize
exactly this dilemma both the
institution as well as the publisher
in max max planck see is it a little
different so there we had long ongoing
discussions about this model and in the
end they decided to not prolong the
contract however it has been a friendly
departure I can reassure you and we are
still talking about other potential
business models with them this is what I
wanted to say about our institutional
open access experiment and I would like
to quickly mention one further
involvement of Springer we are looking
after the best business model when it
comes to open access as much as funders
do as libraries do as scientists do and
one project we are in it it's called
study of open access publishing nice
nicely short into soap project I name
everybody remembers it's the European
Union funded project two years and the
beauty of it is that we have all
different stakeholders present so it's
not only publishers but its funders and
scientific institutes so we are in it
together with Max Planck it's led by the
CERN the high-energy physics Institute
in Geneva which is also working on the
door leading the scope three initiative
there are some other publishers and
funders in it what the study has done so
far is go through the 4700 journals in
the directory of open access journals to
assess their business model and we are
right now in the final phase of writing
up the first report that will definitely
shed some light at which business models
are prevalent right now and the second
part is now a huge survey across
scientists to gather evidence on
attitudes knowledge and experiences with
open access publishing and we all
dissonant disseminate the results of the
both the analysis of the DEA jaye
journals as well as the survey at the
project website okay
thank you very much this is our new
spring outcome open access website
you'll clearly see it even has a section
on authors rights so we are trying to be
transparent and want to work together
with all stakeholders involved thank you
very much so the speakers will come up
to the front now please and anyone who
has a question please come up to the
microphone to ask your question since
we're videotaping today's event for
posterity departure oh please do yes so
I'm gonna challenge patina on your
eighty percent twenty percent argument
because you're still charging the same
amount of the
if you have twenty percent of your
journal is open access but that's fine
people are still paying the same amount
for that eight percent we are open to
what this is the double dipping yeah I
enjoyed the movie as much as suited we
are looking into private adjustments for
for the hybrid turns in general right I
mean this holds to its 42 to tie which
means for individual authors paying open
access fees to make the article openx
you will have to understand that there's
always a certain delay in adjusting
prices for journals with respect to
pioneering these experiments right so I
said we started in late two thousand
seven and you need to monitor the uptake
and you also need to monitor the
fluctuation to expect and then you can
assess the uptake and make the next
steps in a dress pricing we have done
this for 2010 price already for small
number of journals and I can reassure
you we will do that for a bigger number
of journals in the next year because we
see openx uptake grill potato which
bring or publish that information or
just close it make
available so that would be transparently
see yeah i know i mean we asked this
discussion internally a lot of course we
want to be transparent on the other side
we have all these competitors of our
back so this is not a Sal yet it is very
tricky it is definitely you know
confidential business information which
we ideally could share with some it not
with others but if this doesn't work we
America okay questions for ivy you
mentioned in your presentation that on
scope three you currently have at least
a verbal commitment or a promise of
funding that equates to a roughly
seventy percent of the target how was
that calculated what is that how was a
target calculated and how do you figure
that you have seventy percent commitment
at this point in time scope three was
launched by a working party that came
together to develop the ideas behind the
initiative and CERN has certainly led
that but there were others as well that
were part of my bouquet and so forth and
their analysis was based on an analysis
of the worldwide
high energy physics publishing how many
articles are published in which
countries and in which journals and
assigning I presume dollar value which I
don't can't recall how that have that
calculation was done but it was based on
an assessment of the publishing output
and what that likely meant about the the
need to support that publishing so you
know if you take a per article cost and
multiply it by what is known about the
size of that publishing sphere that's
essentially you know probably simplified
way of representing that thank you I a
question about this Springer suggestion
of an extra increment of readership of
the open access articles could you go
into some details about how you actually
studied and came to that conclusion the
reason I'm asking is are you examining
logs and just what can you be certain of
I mean I heard you state that you had
like fifteen to twenty percent more
readers who otherwise would not have
encountered those those papers is that
correct no I realized that I realized
that I yeah what we did is and then was
also triggered by questions I
we chose a subset of open access
articles both from institutional
arrangement so the way you see all good
articles as well as another group of
open choice articles and with our usage
on all those tools eternally we can of
course you know see how much usage is
attributed to use it to reduce who have
licenses content versus how much comes
from and unlicensed either the IPS right
but what you really sorry if I'm
sounding dense here but how do you how
can you come to a conclusion that the
user say is just coming from their home
and doesn't want to turn on their
browser setttings you know thanks I am
very interested in learning how do you
solve them footnotes that are reflected
only in electronic databases or in
electronic resources for example are you
interested in creating mirror sites or
archiving in any way documents that are
referenced in footnotes through their
URL so far I haven't seen anything like
that do you think that will help you
that will give you an advantage over
your competition because no one has
thought about doing that I'm coming from
law where footnotes represent more in
terms of scholarship than the content of
the article I'm coming from an a capella
G so this is new to me but I take it
home
discussing with our editorial ok so I'm
a publisher to from Columbia University
Press from the hood and misunderstood i
like to say Pitino you're a brave person
actually to come and present this I
wanted to ask michael a question about
first copy costs because I'm something
we all think about and talk about and
there's obviously a huge disparity
between what we heard from the
California digital library and what's
going on at Rockefeller and I know from
my experience running a University Press
monograph publisher not a journal
publisher that the cost of peer review
which has to be reflected in first copy
costs for book publishing is even higher
than it is for journals or at least
that's my sense from what I knew at
Hopkins when I was there what I'm
learning a year and getting it some kind
of an understanding really of how one
calculates that so you could look at it
across different kinds of programs and
really think about what the costs are to
the system is a real challenge so I
would ask you if I could and I don't
mean to ask for proprietary information
at all but when you talk about the cost
that it that you incur to publish every
article I've heard a report from na s
national academy of science about their
open access publishing I asked the same
questions about them that's an
institution that is quasi-government is
heavily supported through funding from
an act of Congress significant budget
put forward just to help them publish
everything that they publish is
subsidized you know it's the really the
question of whether those costs reflect
any subsidy that you receive from from
rockefeller you know whether it's space
you know benefit costs any of the things
that go into running a publishing
organization if they don't you know what
are the actual first cop because which
you know I'm again I'm not asking you
anything propriety yeah we don't think
because in those terms anymore because
printing and distribution is such a such
a small part of our budget printing
distribution is only about ten percent
of our budgets now so we think about it
overall expenses we receive no subsidy
from the University we pay rent on space
outside the university because the
university doesn't have space cause as
any surplus that we have at the end beer
goes back in to the University we are
actually expected to turn a surplus into
the University at the end of the year
University of course as the organization
is nonprofit so all your quads for your
derived from your ability to sell
subscribing absolutely can good for you
what it's impressive
cut a question for Mike when we talk to
faculty about open access publishing one
of the concerns we hear and we think to
some extent misunderstandings that we
hear that open access journals are not
the same quality as peer-reviewed now in
some cases that's certainly true but in
other cases like plus it's not and your
description of a sort of track to go
with archival and selective publications
would seem to sort of reinforce that in
a very significant way so you really
would have an environment where open
access was a much lower quality journal
it doesn't have to be so that's lined
with all the subsidies how can you
subsidize a selective open access
journal I think you can publish a
selective open access journal I think
unless you're going to charge ten
thousand dollars per article to the
authors you have to subsidize that in
some way see if I could find a quote but
I have so the issue of lower stringency
peer review being associated with open
access is long-standing super yeah the
first major open access publishing in
biomedical was by wed central and they
codified this lower stringency peer
review at their inception this is from a
news item in nature ten years ago when
bio med center was just getting going
and it was quoting from a biomed central
official who noted that reviewers will
assess scientific accuracy not interest
so by interest I mean I interpret that
to mean whether it's an advance for the
field so that was codified ten years ago
and part my understanding recommend
help me in my understanding is part of
the origin plus was to try to counter
that in codification by biomed central
that said open access publishing is
going to be low quality papers and the
boss guys you think that people like
hair all of my guys and then Pat Brown
pretty serious scientist distinguished
scientists said no we can do it publish
a high quality journal when you do it
open access and that's what they set out
to do as it turns out my understanding
from those guys is that they are crossed
sir even higher than ours to publish
their their flagship journals and it
turns out that they've had to turn to
the subsidy route to continue publishing
very high quality open access journals
there is no question that those are high
quality journals but they are
subsidizing them with with the
publication of an archival trip since
Mike asked for some clarification in the
original business plan for applause the
archive journal was always in the
business plan the way that plus began
though was at a very high level in fact
to counteract as as mike says to
counteract the the impression that the
only way you could do an open access
journal would be at the archival level
that said the a very original plan was
always to do exactly what they're doing
now with plus one they just rolled it
out in reverse order so rather than
starting archival e and then building up
they started with plus biology and plus
medicine and then with the community
noodles and then with plus one but
they're executing a hundred percent on
the original business plan so they're
top-down model has been very successful
and it has been about but I believe that
you're you're also right that and I
don't know what the current costs are
but I think way back when it was like
thirty thousand dollars an article in
biology and medicine yeah um the the
other example is biomed central
surviving central trying to bottom up
approach they for many years published
dozens
dozens of archival journals and then
said we're going to publish a very
selective journal and that's the Journal
of biology which has not been successful
oh I disagree I mean I agreed they
started with a group of very specialized
germs and then they got the submissions
got a higher higher quality and they
decided to add top 20 germs on top and
there's also BMC medicine acting being
BMC medicine certainly the success story
they also have a menara journal which is
much broader than the initial titles on
tropical is ed and then I know that they
were you know together with plus
neglected tropical diseases under the
top of a of their field so I have to
defend my potential so I they are struck
by in your society so there are sixty
percent of faculty are participating in
open access for your project with
Springer and that to me is fascinating
that there's so many faculty and you
seem to think that was a low number no
it's not and I don't know how i phrase
dumbest line okay it's that sixty
percent of the articles that have been
published by using faculty inch bring
your journals have elected sixty percent
and the articles well that still seems
like a high number to me well it's
supposed to be automatic so it should be
closer to a hundred percent of their in
theory should be very
percentage that spent intentionally
declined that option if one assumes that
faculty desire of the Nexus which is
what our faculty library committee tells
us so what was it then expecting only
you know the only authors who would
decline that option on those who maybe
have a patent concern or some so
sometimes our than the or some
philosophical stance that means them to
not select that option so I think the
fact that it's only sixty percent you
know again we're going to do some
surveying of that with you to understand
what's behind those figures but my guess
is it's just not as self-evident to the
corresponding author and as it might
otherwise be right because I think
Google can access I think of faculty and
if faculty aren't interested in open
access then how do we get them
interested because you think about
Springer they have to maximize profits
and open access as a public good so how
do we put the two together and I think a
sustainable business model will be one
more faculty or more involved and I
thought oh sixty percent CDL they've hit
on faculty involvement how what are they
doing that we're not doing and but you
still may be doing something I still
think that's a high where pay the check
right way and we're making it easy they
don't have to modify their publishing
agreement
you know get beaten up over there about
depositing their article repository they
just have to do when they normally do
which is in the article t their journal
Joyce and be exempted so we've made it
easy for them informatik we're writing a
check and let me have their the sixty
percent of the average value for 2009
right we are currently an eighty percent
so we see this increase which has to do
with education obviously right has to do
with the ability of my side which has
just been improved I am Greg Miller from
Rockefeller and I'm the person who sells
all the subscriptions for the time being
I'm interested in the notion of besides
them to the moral argument of the author
that why they would be motivated to come
up with the ten thousand dollars or
fifteen or twenty to have their article
just freely available to the public
forever what is there an incentive in
terms of citations is there any evidence
so far that that articles are being
cited more than open access and I know
that that's it's a tough baseline to get
because I guess you'd have to look at
articles that are similar or are in
similar journals I don't know exactly
how that would be would be done but I'm
just curious as to and by the way we
just that we do we are open access in
the sense that we offer the journals in
an open access way to about 145
countries around the world so we there
is a kind of subsidy there and you
talked about the concentration of there
are more far fewer authors and readers
but I think we also get to a really it's
very us centric these arguments at
Rockefeller about sixty percent of the
subscription revenue comes from
countries outside the US so you know the
Chinese are subsidizing they're paying
for for readership all over China when
they're not necessarily contributing as
many authors Brazil is we have a large
countrywide deal with Brazil so there's
there's a lot of international
restructuring that would go on a lot of
would come to big us research
institutions obviously but I think we
sometimes we lose sight of that
international aspect of the
subscription-based model sorry I had two
things they're completed by night for to
get that one in when I was at the mic
sure so mine was doing this is phil
davis area of study talking about
citations to open access content that
was the first question right now ok my
understanding from phil is that he does
not see an increase and citations to
open access content but he does seem
increasingly kids to open access content
on the web sites exactly kind of early
to study that I think we all want to
study that but I'm given we're just
talking about citation half lives
earlier we probably need a little bit
more time to although maybe it's
beginning to be studying at this point
so there have been conflicting studies
or anything I as I published a study
early odds exciting an open-access
advantage and then Phil Davis came along
as her debunked that article or so but
at the jury's probably still out on that
but Richard something we all want to
send a letter to me
has some results there I'm following it
and I don't see any solution to Liam
bias which is often might make them
based article open access right when you
might of course see an increase the
patient you don't know can you
attributed to the exits aspect to the
quality aspect these are the things no
situs struggle with I personally things
when it will be crazy to to do they are
nervous because they don't have the
scientific power and you know as much as
those research groups while working on
it this far as the internationalization
of I think you're absolutely right and
that Patrick's supports the point that
the readership is much broader and
authorship and so that that leads to a
much wider distribution of revenue and
in negotiation typical negotiations with
publishers we often say well we're
trying to keep our costs in our
increases low you know go get your
revenue growth in the developing world
because that's where were you where
there is a lot of growth and so I think
we sort of acknowledge that I think it
was an ivs presentation it was in it was
briefly touched on is the deal the part
of this perception problem for open
access is the ISI impact factor and the
academy's the broad academy's need to
have a tenure process validated by a
peer-reviewed publication I wondered if
any one of the three of you would like
to talk about that as a larger issue and
Harold Varmus presented at the in
November at the association of american
medical colleges made a plea to the
Academy which is basically you know
you're paying these prices because you
actually set the model up and what are
you going to do as administrators to
change that model so to change the model
needed to change
stop relying on or reduce reliance on or
two or to make it a little bit more
transparent about the ISI impact factor
being a lagging indicator of the value
of a journal or to what was mentioned
just a couple of seconds ago about the
fact that just because it's in a high
impact journal doesn't necessarily mean
it's high value research and my senses
everyone recognizes those challenges but
there no one has identified as
substitute substitute that in the tenure
process where new committees still need
watch some sort of proxy they're not
going to read the articles and evaluate
them on their merits and they want some
sort of proxy and journal Brad and
impacted is a proxy and no one has that
I know of has come up with an
alternative proxying that would be
efficient I mean I tend to think that
that the system would change more
rapidly and people wanted it to change
if those who write and those who are
involved in the scholarly communication
process and in ten year and almost
wanted to change and finally find those
the right ways to do it and I don't mean
that folks don't want change but then
the mechanisms the past isn't that isn't
self-evident but things can change very
quickly you have certain if the
conditions are right so a lot of our
experimentation is predicated on
generating a lot of experimentation so
that conditions can be disrupted and
make the right conditions can a bird we
can we can learn whether there are in
the right conditions for some sort of
transformation but so I tend to think
that if if the right proxy if someone
developer right proxy it could be very
influential but it just hasn't happened
yet under there it's as publishers I
don't think we are going to change that
system that's another system as that
happen within university
administration's as publishers what we
can do is try to provide a little more
information besides having tenure
committees just rely on a proprietary
number provide advice by some
corporation you know the simplest thing
to think of as usage sets so we can now
provide usage stats for individual
articles now how much way is going to be
given to usage stats depends on the
tenure committees but we're beginning to
at least be able to provide something in
addition to just the impact that
specially the sound really drilling down
to the article ever right we see classes
from
central experimenting with an article
number matrix at their website now how
this is taken into account by
decision-makers is important enough to
publish are there any other questions
okay I guess we'll wrap up then thank
you very much to our panelists today you
are great and thank you very much to
everyone for coming and we'll see you
again at our next event and there's
handouts on the chairs which has the
next event on it so please take a look
at it and I hope you all come out for
the next the next one as well thank you
very much